our speaker today is a friend of our
college and we are proud of that fact
proud to know him proud to benefit from
knowing him which we do greatly he's an
English guy he's a BA MA and PhD in
English theology and divinity he has an
honorary degree from Hillsdale College
where he gave one of our very best
commencement speeches that I have ever
heard in which he proceeded on a career
of making fun of and humiliating the
name of the College at great length it
will be more of that crap today
he is a learning Devine first Protestant
now a Catholic we all were familiar with
this phenomenon around here and also it
goes back the other way sometimes that's
the thing you got to get used to if you
call me up and say I'm very upset by my
child has changed churches from
Protestant Catholic or the other way I
always say thank God he didn't take up
devil worship that was my comment when I
heard that Professor Ward had changed
his affiliation he's been a deacon in
the Church of England and a priest who
chaplain of Peter house what else has he
done he teaches at Houston Baptist now
until he comes up here I guess the thing
that brought him to my notice and many
of our notice early was that he's one of
the leading experts on CS Lewis his book
he's written several now and he's got
more coming but his book called planet
Narnia contains one of those great
insights that scholars get once in a
while and it's why they don't get many
nobody gets many in his
career most don't get any like this but
it was thought of CS Lewis that he was
not a very careful writer and that to
his friend tokine was much better and if
you judge the the fiction that they
wrote for children and science fiction
and fantasy that tokine was much better
and of course there's that story the
tokine disapproved of lewis's fiction so
that's sad when you hear things like
that and so Michael Ward comes along to
explain to us that these books that we
all love are serious books and that
comes to him because he has the eyes to
see serious things from the human point
of view which of course always involves
both reverence and humor a great man
Michael
[Applause]
there's a time to scatter stones and a
time to gather stones together Thank You
president Ahn for your introduction good
morning good day everybody
senior class especially other students
faculty staff trustees honored guests
50-year alumni mr. and mrs. Babbitt mr.
strike it's a great delight for me to be
back here at Hillsdale to speak at this
spring convocation and to mark the
groundbreaking for the new chapel the
building which I believe will be not
only the jewel in the crown of the
Hillsdale estate but a fine example
nationally and indeed internationally of
church architecture in an educational
setting on my last visit two years ago
when I spoke at commencement
I drew attention to the one serious
deficiency of Hillsdale College and it
is the only one I'm aware of namely the
strikingly in adequate attention given
here to the life and work of Winston
Churchill
[Applause]
now I was joking of course I have full
faith in your church iliyan credentials
and all the more so now that I see you
are building an actual church on a hill
[Applause]
I know it's a chapel on a hill not a
church on a hill but Churchill is funny
and Chapel Hill is not begging the
pardon of all Tar Heels present admiring
earlier this morning as I was the statue
of Churchill in Boocock and the statue
of Margaret Thatcher in the quadrangle
and reflecting on the fact that you've
invited this Englishman to give this
convocation address I began to wonder
where the Hillsdale had received the
right memo from the White House the aim
remember is make America great again not
make America great written the game
shortly after convocation is over we'll
go to the site of what will be the new
building Christ's Chapel as its to be
known and with all due ceremony various
people I'm told will pick up a speed and
lift a small pile of Earth from one
place to another when all that's done a
sliver of dirt a little gash of brown
will lie freshly exposed to the sky new
ground will have been broken and so the
college will have formally declared the
start of its latest and in some ways
perhaps its greatest ever Enterprise the
building of a chapel to the glory of
Christ this chapel will be built not to
the glory of Hillsdale though it will
redound mightily and rightly to the
credit and renown of this College not to
the glory of the benefactors though
their generosity and public spiritedness
can hardly be saluted with sufficient
gratitude not to the glory of the
students who in future will worship
their graduate their perform music their
wonderful though all those things may
certainly are it will be built to the
glory of Christ who himself glories in
our educational endeavors our
philanthropic benefactions our pupillary
activity
for God is no man's debtor now I feel
fondly towards this new chapel and it's
not even been built yet
and that's because two years ago I was
in Houston one Sunday morning and I went
for the very first time in my life to a
church called st. Teresa's in a part of
Houston called Sugar Land and I went
there I must confess partly to see what
they make churches off in Sugar Land
Candi pillars of licorice I was hoping
for walls of marzipan roofs of chocolate
wood Willy Wonka give the sermon what a
jelly baby be baptized when we have
communion with bread or gingerbread the
reality was far better than any Hansel
and Gretel fantasy I could have
entertained cinta Rivas was beautiful at
any rate it was beautiful inside outside
it was no great shakes but I asked and
discovered that the interior had
recently been renovated from top to toe
and so impressed was I after I got home
that I spent a long time browsing the
website of the architectural firm you
did the job the more I looked at the
work of this architect who might never
heard of before I never heard of any
American architects before I must
confess the more I was impressed indeed
astonished by its quality here was
architecture that lifted the spirits
that assisted you in worship rather than
causing you to wonder whether God exists
we've all been in those churches and
here was an architect who evidently knew
and respected the history and the
traditions of architecture and who was
bringing the timeless principles of that
art form to new life in the modern day
not long after as I was in California
and I took a deliberate three-day detour
to see another commissioned by the same
architect the chapel at Thomas Aquinas
College this was his work both inside
and out and this was stunning miraculous
that such a work could be put up in the
modern day so when in May of that year
2015 I came to Hillsdale to give the
commencement address and dr. David
Whalen told me of the plans to build a
new chapel here I said to him almost
dreamily you are going to get Duncan
strike to design it on and he said yes
we are
what are the chances of that at Oxford
we are trained to make a little
knowledge go a long way and here the one
single fact I knew about American
architects went straight in the bull's
eye as if I knew all about American
architecture so I'm very fond of this
Chapel I think it's got a great future
ahead of it it's also got a great past
behind it
Hillsdale College as you well know was
founded in the first half of the 19th
century at 16 minutes to 7 I mean 1844
article 6 of the college Constitution
states religious culture in particular
shall be conserved by the college and by
the selection of instructors and other
practicable expedients it shall be a
conspicuous aim to teach by precept and
example the essentials of the Christian
faith and religion those practicable
expedients are now being understood with
a whole new level of seriousness and
holy ambition 173 years after its
founding Hillsdale formally begins today
what I understand will be a two-year
process of building a suitably sized
suitably special suitably sacred space -
thus helping to fulfill that original
aim or for founder's a hundred and
seventy-three years good things come to
those who wait sometimes you just have
to be patient there are flowers cacti
I'm told that bloom only once every
couple of centuries I was taken to see
one once in the Botanic Gardens in
Oxford amazing thing though that the
smell was awful smells like rotting
flesh but blast by the way I know that
we're told that Americans and Brits have
different perspectives that in America a
hundred years of a long time while in
Britain a hundred miles is a long way
well that's not always true I've
traveled nearly four thousand miles to
be with you today
Elmas actually not a very long distance
to be among friends in funny Hilldale
and he'll fail itself as I know very
well how they routed historical sense
you're fully aware that one hundred and
seventy three years is no great delay in
the grand scheme of things indeed it
could be regarded as rather hasty I used
to be chaplain of Peter house the oldest
college in Cambridge which though
founded in 1284 didn't get round to
building its own dedicated chapel till
1628 that's nearly half past four I mean
that three hundred forty four years 173
is almost exactly half that so really
what you're doing today is terribly
hasty you should slow down incidentally
that chapel at Peter house was built
under the presidency of Matthew Wren who
was uncle of none other than Christopher
Wren builder of st. Paul's Cathedral
president arm mentioned that his
daughter Alice has studied at Notre Dame
under Duncan strike well if mr. strike
is not already America's Christopher
Wren let's hope miss Alice on one day
we'll take that Laurel herself this
building this church College Baptist
Church have served Hillsdale well for
most of those hundred and seventy-three
years but now the time is ripe for the
full flowering to move from the good to
the best to the college's own
purpose-built suitably sized Chapel the
quadrangle will be completed that
providentially preserved gap between
grew [ __ ] and the Dow Center will be
filled up and a permanent place of
worship place of ceremony face of beauty
and dignity will emerge religious
culture shall more hospitably than ever
before be conserved by the college the
founders aim is frakked if eyeing but
they we're breaking new ground today
there's no absolute novelty occurring
it's not mere change that's happening
but a synthesis of change and continuity
the nature of the college is being more
fully realized becoming more itself
finding a more developed way in which to
teach by precept and example the
essentials of the Christian religion
religion tends to get a bad rap these
days and from two directions on the one
hand we hear people say that they are
spiritual they're not religious they may
be interested in Christianity but
certainly not a religiosity religion
here means something like ritualism mere
formalism the externals of faith on the
other hand some people take religion to
mean folly or superstition or even
fanaticism as when Richard Dawkins says
that religion flies planes into
buildings but science flies rockets to
the moon surely one of the most fattiest
things ever said by an Oxford professor
and I've heard a lot of fatuous things
in Oxford I've even said a few of them
myself
why do I think that's a fatuous well
firstly because religion and science
being abstract nouns not people don't
actually do you anything good or bad
they are not agents and secondly because
if we're going to play that game of
ascribing agency to abstract nouns one
might just as well say religion gives us
mother Teresa while science gives us
mustard gas it's much better simply to
say that there can be bad religion and
good religion there can be bad religion
done well there can be good religion
done badly there can be mediocre
religion done well or badly just as is
the case with science so for many years
I've been on a mission to reclaim the
word religion from this verb aside that
it's been suffering religion doesn't
mean either formalism or fanaticism
etymologically it means rather something
like tying back together we leaky on
religion ting really guttering finding
the the unifying reality behind
disparate
clearances seeking oneness integration
wholeness that a theory of everything as
Stephen Hawking might say religion in
this sense is the opposite of analysis
analysis from the Greek analysis means
loosening up not tying back together but
loosening up there is of obviously of
course naturally a place for analysis we
do often need to pull things apart to
dissect them but analysis serves
synthesis doesn't it it's not an end in
itself you disassemble the engine of
your car when it's malfunctioning in
order to find out the problem and then
put it back together so that it's in
working order again it wouldn't run more
smoothly if you just left it in pieces
on the garage floor you cut open the
human body to remove the tumor or the
bullet or whatever it may be then you
sew up the incision religiously to bring
back health to the organism health that
depends upon integration health that
won't survive perpetual loosening up you
break new ground for a similar reason
you dig up a whole load of Earth rocks
and roots you loosen it and scatter it
about removing some bits relocating
other bits and not only physically with
the earth but intellectually with
architectural principles you analyze you
loosen up what makes for a good building
you analyze what makes for a good
building in this particular place you
analyze what makes for a good building
in this particular place for this
particular body of people and all this
analysis takes years there's mass and
noise and expense and disagreements and
people look at you like you're crazy the
interruptions for normal life go on for
years all sorts of unexpected problems
crop up along the way and this is when
it's going well but strength rejoices in
the challenge and the true crop is not
these disturbances these echoes of
primordial chaos
the earth was formless and void rather
the true harvest of all these efforts
will be a noble building a thing of
beauty and a joy forever in which an old
aliens shall flourish both individually
and corporately and from which the God
whose given us everything in Christ can
be given back the best we have to offer
which is all too little but in which
offering we transcend ourselves and
therefore most truly find ourselves so
analysis I maintain is not an end in
itself but is religion an end in itself
isn't it possible to be too religious to
be so interested in unity and oneness
that you never look for change can't the
religious impulse devolve into a kind of
rigidity or frozenness
a paralysis in which the way we've
always done things must be the way we
always do things for ever and ever I'm
in well that is a danger
yes obscurantism the Luddite impulse
tying things back together so tight that
life becomes one big strangulating
corset that is a danger true religion
however should always be corrigible both
self-critical and open to correction
from without open to revision in the
light of new knowledge in response to
new situations not jumping in upon
itself or always ratcheting up the
interior tension but periodically
relaxing taking stock surveying new
horizons like the heart but now
contracts now expands in the history of
Christianity st. Peter and st. Paul are
the great archetypes we do well have in
mind when we think like this st. Peter
is the rock that's what the name Peter
means you don't have to be a Catholic to
accept
that Peter was the first Bishop of Rome
and the defining function of any Bishop
is to sit rock-like stationary in a
chair a cathedra to be a focus of unity
for the flock which he regulates with
his shepherd's crook by rod and thy
staff they comfort me
the Petrin principle provides for fixity
certainty a still point in a turning
world but st. Paul is the missionary the
apostle to the Gentiles who goes all
over the Mediterranean spreading the
word founding new churches tackling
practical problems developing new
theological understandings firing off
letters left right and center and once
even challenging Peter to his face and
this all line principle is important
because I recognize that not everyone at
Hillsdale calls themselves Christian you
may not be much interested in the life
of the new chapel when it comes you have
other fish to fry
you may even wish respectfully to
challenge this or that aspect of hills
dales priorities that's a good role to
fulfill in a community every human
organization needs Paul's as well as
Peters Paul as as well as Petra's if it
was all about Peter things would petrify
if it was all about Paul things would be
appalling
you need both you need both you need the
rock in Rome and the one who roams and
rocks to principles in tension with each
other
respecting each other but both seeking
one ultimate goal serving the same
beating heart the heart itself is more
important than whether the blood within
it happens to be a being or flowing true
religion therefore needs to be
understood in two senses it both does
and is theirs the particular religious
impulse a function that tying back
together but then there's religion
itself the overall pattern the continual
rhythmic regular process of now tying
back now loosening up
neither Peter nor Paul with an end in
himself each was a servant of Christ the
two pointed to the one the unity beyond
themselves and that greater unity that
final law ultimate real igg amounting is
why it's so fitting that this new chapel
will be known as Christ's chapel for
Christ is the one in whom all things
hold together both the tightening and
the loosening both the systolic and the
diastolic both the rock and the rocking
today we break new ground we challenge
the rock so to speak we do something
very poor line very an elliptical
scattering earth this way and that but
we do so with an aim in mind to develop
and extend that ground into a new unity
and enlarged oneness we have a Petrin
end in view there is a time to scatter
stones and a time to gather stones
together may earth be better and
heaven be richer from a life and labor
of Hillsdale College Armand
[Applause]